[Musique]
sabu mais comme ça au moment là les
ouates un trop de la balle
deux ans après cette pandémie qui nous a
flingué la vie quand même on peut le
dire les chinois sont en passe
figurez-vous d'éradiquer le virus grâce
à un renforcement des spéciales et là ça
va vous intéresser raf regardez on
regarde bien c'est sur des poissons pour
le coup en fait c'est sur le marché de
shanghai donc avant d'acheter des
boissons il faut bien sûr s'assurer
qu'ils n'ont pas le qu'ovide pouvoir les
manger reste désormais à les poissons
mais voilà ça bah c'est la fourchette
qui va à la bouche et pas le contraire
je l'aï entendu cette phrase mais c'est
pas alain delon qui l'a prononcer mais
au point parfois d'être comme possédés
par ses démons c'est ce que vous écrivez
et de surgir un fou et de cuir à la main
même mes chiens je ne frappe pas avec
ceux fouet vous gardez pas le souvenir
de la souffrance physique mais les mots
oui ils ont laissé des plaques ont été
longues à cicatriser
c'est normal c'est normal
[Musique]
c'est chez nous où c'est bon
excusez moi de
contrôler un personnage est originaire à
tour sur votre merci
au point de demander si vous aimez cette
question elle même aujourd'hui à 56 ans
mais pas complètement une réponse
aujourd'hui 56 ans wade de vous relire
aujourd'hui encore à 56 ans je n'ai pas
la réponse à cette question assez et
mais non pas du tout écrit dans j'ai mal
lu aujourd'hui à 56 ans je n'ai pas la
réponse à savoir si est-ce que je même
suffisamment
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'appelle anaconda
serviable
le 1 le 2 ou le 9 à votre service
je vais essayer le 2
[Musique]
sélectionnez
veuillez nous excuser pour cette
interruption des programmes
il est venu vous chercher aussi à la
sortie vous allez chercher tous les
trois j'espère vous avez des basques et
aussi des anecdotes sympathiques
mais moi ya aussi des choses sympas dans
ce bouquin quand même
mais bien sûr mais c'est aussi ce que
vous racontez bien sûr dans les gestions
s'il a choisi par les trucs sympathiques
bien sûr bon d'accord et enfin axel de
tarlé oscar du meilleur décor parce que
quand même depuis le temps à france télé
vous faites partie des meubles
avant que quelqu'un ne fasse une will
smith 1
c à vous c'est vous massez vous allez
le geste est beau
moi savons gérer une réflexion de roger
couderc qui commentait français kw 177
et qui en parlant de gérard cholley 10
ou rebelle droite ou bien pur où ils
anesthésie un écossais et ça prouve le
monde dans lequel au vin qu'on a changé
de monde de coiffes will smith présente
ses excuses après avoir giflé l'acteur
chris rock pendant la cérémonie des
oscars le comédien a publié un message
sur son compte instagram je voudrais
publiquement te demander pardon crise ce
que j'ai fait était déplacée j'ai eu
tort
la violence sous quelque forme que ce
soit et toxiques et destructrice mais
actions n'ont pas été représentatif de
l'homme que je veux être on aimerait
vraiment aux etats-unis sans un petit
côté ridicule à il est battu et commence
à lui à la hausse aucune habitude faire
ça